the jurogan experience when we take down
something that
that we're not supposed to
i mean that that is like
i mean that's the worst i mean that's
like discern like how like say like
these christian facebook pages i i don't
know how they found out that 19 of 20
were fake but if someone just says i am
bob smith and they post as bob smith and
they have a photograph and they but
really what they're doing is trying to
uh talk [ __ ] about joe biden and get
people to vote republican in the
midterms like how
what how do you know whether someone's
real or not like this is the big
argument with elon and twitter
because elon asked twitter like what
percentage of your
website is filled with bots and they say
five percent and he says i don't believe
you i think it's higher
and let's find out how you've come to
this conclusion yeah and you know
they're
i believe they said that they just took
a hundred random
twitter pages and looked at the
interaction and there's some sort of an
algorithm they applied to it but how do
you discern
yeah so i mean i think estimating the
overall
prevalence is is one thing but i think
that the question of you know looking at
a page and is this page authentic i
think that there's
a bunch of signals around that one of
the things that we try to do is for
large pages we try to make sure that we
know who the admin of that page is we
don't necessarily if you should be able
to run an anonymous page you don't
necessarily need to out yourself and say
who you are running it but we want to
make sure that we sort of have
like an identity for that person on file
so that way we know
like at least behind the scenes that
that person is real
um
for certain political things i think
having a sense of
what country they're originating from i
mean some of that you can do just by
looking at where their server traffic
comes from like is the ip address coming
from romania or you know is or
um
because if if it's like an ad in some
other country's election then you know
you probably want to make sure that
that ad is is um
you know especially in countries that
have laws around that are are like are
coming from someone who's a valid
citizen or like at least in that place
so there's a bunch of
i think
i don't know what one theme in my world
view around this stuff when it gets to
some of the stuff that we talked about
before it's like i don't think that this
stuff is black and white or that you're
ever going to have like a perfect ai
system
um i think it's all trade-offs all the
way down right and it's and
and you could either you could build a
system and you can either be overly
aggressive and capture a higher percent
of the bad guys but then also by
accident take out some number of good
guys or you could be a little more
lenient and
say okay no the cost of taking out any
number of good guys is too high so we're
going to tolerate having you know just a
little bit more
like more bad guys on the system
these are values questions right around
what what do you value more
and
and those are those are super tricky
questions and
part of what i've struggled with around
this is
i didn't get into this
to basically judge those things i got
into this to design technology that
helps people connect right it's like
and like
i mean you could probably tell when we
spent the first hour talking about the
metaverse and the future of basically
building this whole technology roadmap
to basically give people this realistic
sense of presence it's like
that's what i'm here to do right um so
this whole thing that's like arbitrating
what is okay and what is not i obviously
have to be involved in that because this
is at some level you know i run the
company and um
and i i can't just abdicate that but
but i also don't think
that as a matter of governance you want
all of that
decision-making vested in
one individual so i think one of the
things that you know our country and our
government gets right is the separation
of powers so you know one of the things
that i tried to create is we created
this oversight board it's an independent
board
with that basically we appointed people
whose kind of paramount value is free
expression but they also balance that
with things like when is there going to
be real harm to others in terms of
safety or privacy or other other human
rights issues
and
and basically
that board
people in our community can appeal cases
to when they think that we got it wrong
and that board actually gets to make the
final binding decision not us so
in a way
i actually think that that is a more
legitimate form of governance than
having just a team internally that makes
these decisions or you know maybe some
of them go up to me although i don't
spend a ton of my time on on on this on
a day-to-day basis but like
i think it's generally good to have some
kind of separation of powers where
you're architecting the governance so
that way you you have different
stakeholders and different people who
can make these decisions and it's not
just like one private company that's
making
decisions even about what just happens
on our platform
how do you guys handle things when
they're
a big news item that's controversial
like there was a lot of attention on
twitter
during the election because of the
hunter biden laptop story the new year
yeah
yeah so you guys censored that as well
so we took a different path than twitter
um i mean basically the background here
is the fbi i think basically came to us
some some folks on our team it was like
hey
um just so you know like you should be
on high alert there was
we we thought there was a lot of russian
propaganda in the 2016 election we have
it on notice that basically there's
about to be
some kind of dump of of um
uh
that's similar to that so just be
vigilant so our protocol is different
from twitter's what twitter did is they
said you can't share this at all um we
didn't do that what we do is we have um
if something is reported to us as
potentially
um misinformation important
misinformation
we also this third party fact-checking
program because we don't want to be
deciding what's true and false and
for the
i think it was
five or seven days when it was basically
being
um
being determined whether it was false um
the distribution on facebook was
decreased but people were still allowed
to share it so you could still share it
you could still consume it so when i say
the distribution has decreased it got
shared how does that work basically the
ranking a news feed was a little bit
less so fewer people saw it than would
have otherwise so it definitely by what
percentage i don't know off the top my
head but it's it's it's meaningful but i
mean but basically
a um
a lot of people are still able to share
it
we got a lot of complaints that that was
the case um you know obviously this is a
hyper political issue so depending on
what side of the political spectrum you
either think we didn't censor it enough
or censored it way too much but right
but we weren't sort of as black and
white about it as twitter we just kind
of thought hey look if if the fbi which
i still
view as a legitimate institution in this
country it's a very professional law
enforcement they come to us and tell us
that we need to be on guard about
something then i want to take that
seriously did they specifically say you
need to be on guard about that story
i i no i don't remember if it was that
specifically but it was it basically fit
the pattern when something like that
turns out to be real
is there regret for
not
having it evenly distributed and for
throttling the distribution of that
story
what do you mean evenly distributed i
mean
evenly in that it's not suppressed it's
not yeah yeah yeah i mean it sucks yeah
yeah i mean because i mean it turned out
after the fact i mean the fact directors
looked into it no one was able to say it
was false right so so basically it had
this period where it was getting less
distribution
um
so yeah i mean i i but i think like
i think it probably it sucks though i
think in the same way
that probably having to go through like
a criminal trial but being proven
innocent in the end sucks like it still
sucks to have have like that you had to
go through a criminal trial but at the
end you're free um so it's i i don't
know if the answer would have been
don't do anything or don't have any
process i think the process was pretty
reasonable you know it's we still let
people share it but but obviously you
don't want situations like that but
certainly much more reasonable than
twitter stance and it's probably also
the case of armchair quarterbacking
right or at least monday morning
quarterbacking i should say because
in the moment you had reason to believe
based on the fbi talking to you that it
wasn't real and that there was going to
be some propaganda so what do you do
yeah and then if you just let it get out
there and what if it changes the
election it turns out to be [ __ ]
that's a real problem and
i would imagine that those kind of
decisions are the most difficult the
decisions of like what is allowed and
what is not allowed yeah i mean what
would you do in that situation i don't
know what i would do i would have to
like really thoroughly well first of all
you're dealing with the new york post
which is one of the oldest newspapers in
the country so i would i would say uh i
would want to talk to someone uh from
the new york post and i would say how
did you come up with this data like
where where are you getting the
information from how do you know whether
or not this is correct
and
then you have to make a decision because
they might have got duped it's it's very
it's hard because everybody wants to
look at it after the fact now that we
know that the
laptop was real and it was a legitimate
story and there is potential corruption
involved with him
what
we we think oh that should not have been
restricted that should not have been
banned from sharing on twitter
right
i think everybody agrees with that even
twitter agrees with that but the thing
is then they didn't think that in the
beginning they thought it was fake so
what do they do like if something comes
along and the republicans cook up some
scheme to make it look like joe biden's
a terrible person and they only do it so
that they can win the election but it's
really just propaganda
what what are you supposed to do with
that you're supposed to not allow that
to be distributed so if they think
that's the case it makes sense to me
that they would try to stop it but i
just don't think that they looked at it
hard enough when the new york post is
talking about it
you know they're pretty smart about what
they release and what they don't release
if they're do if they're going over
some
data from a laptop and you could talk to
a person but again like this is just one
story like one individual store like how
many of these pop up every day
especially regards to polarizing issues
like climate change or covid or or you
know foreign policy or ukraine
anytime there's like a really
controversial issue where some people
think that it's imperative that you take
a very specific stance
and you can't have the other stance like
that those moments
on social media
those trouble a lot of people because
they don't know
why
certain things get censored or certain
things get promoted
yeah i i agree
and it's like to be in your spot and i
was one of the things that i really
wanted to talk to you about is this
because like to be in your spot must be
insanely difficult
to have
no matter what decision you make you're
going to have a giant chunk of people
that are upset at you
and there might be a right way to handle
it but i don't know what the [ __ ] right
way is well i think the right way
is
to establish principles for governance
that try to be balanced and not have the
decision making too centralized because
i think that it's hard for people to
to accept that like
some team at meta or that i personally
am making all these decisions
and i think people should be skeptical
about any
so much concentration around that so
that's why
a lot of the innovation that i've tried
to push for in governance is around
things like establishing this oversight
board so that way you have people who
are luminaries around expression
from all over the world but also in in
the in the u.s um you know i mean folks
like michael mcconnell who's i mean he's
a stanford professor he's like
just he was afraid which um
which republican president appointed him
but i mean he was i think going to be
considered for the supreme court at some
point i mean he's a very um
very prominent and and kind of
celebrated
free expression advocate and he helped
me set the thing up and
i think like setting up forms of
governance around
that are independent of us
that basically
get the final say on a bunch of these
decisions
and that's that's a step in the right
direction i mean in the the hunter biden
case that you talked about before you
know i don't want our company to decide
what's misinformation and what's not so
when we work with with third parties and
basically
let different different organizations do
that no i mean then you have the
question of are those organizations
biased or not and that's that's a that's
a very difficult question but at least
we're not the ones who are basically
sitting here deciding we're not the
ministry of truth for the world that's
deciding whether everything is true or
not so
i'd say um
this is not a solved problem
controversies aren't going away um you
know i think that there's
it is interesting that the us
um
is actually more polarized than
than most other countries so i think
sitting in the u.s and it's easy to
extrapolate and say hey
it probably feels this way around the
whole world
and from the social science research
that i've seen that's not actually the
case there's a bunch of countries
where social media is just as prominent
but polarization is either flat or has
declined slightly so there's something
kind of
different happening in the u.s
but
but for better or worse i mean it does
seem like like like the the next several
years do seem like they're set up to be
quite polarized so i i tend to agree
with you there are going to be a bunch
of different decisions like this that
that come up um
because of the scale of what we do
almost every major world event has some
angle that's like the facebook or
instagram or whatsapp angle
about how the services are used in it so
yeah i think just establishing as much
as possible independent governance
you